in the next few videos I'm going to
embark on something that will we're just
result in a formula that's pretty
straightforward to apply and in most in
most statistics classes you'll just see
that end product but I actually want to
show how to get there but I just want to
warn you right now it's going to be a
lot of hairy math most of it hairy
algebra and then we're actually going to
have to do a little bit of calculus near
the end we're gonna have to do a few
partial derivatives so if any of that
sounds daunting or it sounds like
something that will discourage you in
some way you don't have to watch it you
could skip to the end and just get the
formula that we're going to derive but I
at least find it pretty satisfying to
actually derive it so what we're going
to think about here is let's say we have
n points let's say we have n points on a
coordinate plane we have n points here
and they all don't have to be in the
first quadrant but just for simplicity
or visualization I'll draw them all in
the first quadrant so let's say I have
this point right over here let me do
them in different colors let's say I
have this point right over here and that
coordinate is x1 y1 and then let's say I
have another point over here I have do
that in a different color okay I have
another point over here we're going to
the coordinates there are x2 y2 and then
I could keep adding points and I could
keep drawing them you know we just have
a ton of points there and there and
there and we go all the way to the end
point all the way to the actual end
point maybe it's over here the end point
is over here and we're just going to
call that x + y n so we have n points
here I haven't drawn all of the actual
points but what I want to do is find a
line that minimizes the squared
distances to these different points so
let's think about it let's visualize
that line for a second so there's going
to be some line and I'm going to try to
draw a line that kind of approximates
what these points are doing so let me
draw this line here so maybe the line
might look something like this I'm going
to try my best to approximate it so
maybe it looks something like that
actually we draw it a little bit
different maybe it looks something
something like that I don't even know
what it looks like right now what we
want to do is minimize the squared error
from each of these points to the line so
let's think about what that means so the
if the equation of this line right here
the equation of that line is y is equal
to MX plus B and this just comes
straight out of Algebra one this is the
slope of the line this is the slope of
the line and this is the y-intercept
this is actually the point zero B right
here
zero B what I want to do is I want to
find and that's what the the topic of
the next few videos are going to be I
want to find an M and a B so I want to
find these two things that define this
line so that it minimizes the squared
error so let me define what the error
even is so for each of these points the
error between it and the line is the
vertical distance so this right here so
this right here we can call error one
error error one and then this right here
this right here would be error two it
would be the vertical distance between
that point and the line or you could
think of it the Y value of this point
and the y value of the line and you just
keep going all the way to the end point
between the Y value of this point and
the y value of the line so this error
right here error one if you think about
it it is this value right here this Y
value it is this Y value it's equal to Y
1 minus this Y value well what's this Y
value going to be well over here we have
X is equal to X 1 and this point is the
point M X 1 plus B you took you take X 1
into this equation of the line and
you're going to get this point right
over here so that's literally going to
be equal to M X 1 plus B that's that
first error we can keep doing it with
all of the points this error right over
here is going to be y 2 minus M X 2 plus
B is y 2 and then this right here this
point right here is M X 2 plus B the
value when you take
x2 into this line and then we keep going
all the way to our endpoint this error
right here is going to be Y n minus M
minus M X n m xn plus B now what we want
to do so if we wanted to just take the
straight up sum of the errors we could
just sum these things up but we want to
do is minimize the square of the error
between each of these points each of
these endpoints in the line so let me
draw refine let me define I'll do this
in a new color let me define the squared
error against this line as being equal
to the sum of these squared errors so
this this error right here or error one
we could call it is y1 minus mx1 plus B
and we're going to square it so this is
the error 1 squared and then we're going
to go to error 2 squared error 2 squared
is y 2 y 2 minus y 2 minus M X 2 plus B
and then we're going to square that
error we're squaring this error and then
we keep going we're going to keep going
we're going to go n spaces or n points I
should say we keep going all the way to
this n error the nth error is going to
be yn minus M X n plus B and then we're
going to square it and then we are going
to square it so this is the squared
error of the line and I want to find and
we're going to over the next few videos
is I want to find find the M and B that
minimizes minimizes this value that
minimizes the squared error of the of
this line right here so if you if you
view this as the best metric for how
good a fit a line is we're going to try
to find the best fitting line for these
points and I'll continue in the next
video because I find that with these
very hairy math
problems it's good to kind of just
deliver one concept of the time and it
also minimizes my probability of making
a mistake